hey guys tim ferriss here i am asked
very often about the spices that i use
for cooking and in fact even though I
wrote the 4-hour chef and I've
experimented with hundreds of different
things and in fact I'll just show you
very briefly that I have like racks and
racks of spices that many of which I had
custom-made Ra's al hanout Harr Italian
herb mix English mixed spice Chinese
five spice blend some of these I had
made specifically for experimentation to
the 4-hour chef but when I'm cooking at
home there are just a handful of things
I use all the time so first and foremost
we have the basics I'm going to come
back to the basics these are what I use
most often all right so what do we have
here when in doubt just use the C's what
does that mean when in doubt I use
cayenne I use cumin I use coriander I
use cinnamon which is below so the C's
you can make something delicious just
using C's aside from the C's chili also
so crushed chili Cayenne coriander cumin
cinnamon different types cinnamon etc
right otherwise ginger hugely
underutilized gingers just fantastic
turmeric excellent for anti-inflammatory
properties other health benefits and
also color very very useful for
scrambled eggs for instance and then
garlic and I use not just powdered
garlic of granulated garlic also use
fresh for a squeezed garlic in which
case I'm going to use this beast this
couldn't drink on this is the best
garlic press you will possibly find and
it's not inexpensive but it is fantastic
and worth every dollar so that's one of
many tools that I have here which would
get into another time so those are the
spices alright but what else do we have
we have salt and pepper okay I always
have this out alright I don't have
a salt shaker I just put salt into a
container like this I can pinch it I can
drop it in anything that I happen to be
cooking this is kosher salt regular
kosher salt if you want to get a little
fancier then I also use what you could
consider a finishing salt so when I cook
I will use the kosher salt if I'm using
a finishing salt meaning right before
presenting the food or plating the food
I'll use Maldon sea salt and you can
also get smoked I use the normal sea
salt flakes a lot more I probably have a
dozen different types of salt 90% of the
time I'm using that and I'm using this
this has a really nice flaky texture to
it and then we have pepper
all right so black Tellicherry berries
just load them up in here this is also
in terms of high quality never want to
buy another one the unicorn
black pepper or pepper mill is just
fantastic and you might ask yourself or
say to me
come on Faris give me a break how much
of a difference kind of good pepper mill
make try this thing it is amazing it is
expensive but every one that I bought
one of these for as a gift has just been
astonished with the difference now let's
talk about citrus and lemon this is very
very useful
a lot of professional chefs use citrus
in the way that they might use salt so
lemon juice is an extremely important
component limes less so a little less
versatile in my kitchen I use it for all
sorts of stuff everything from scrambled
eggs to meats to you name it
salads certainly vegetables when in
doubt you know add a little bit of
citrus and see what happens so this is
Santa Cruz organic 100% juice this is
unsweetened you can see zero calories
and then we have vinegar so this is
sherry vinegar there are many different
types of vinegar but sherry vinegar very
often will have as you can see zero
calories and
if you look at balsamic vinegar many of
them are over sweetened and that is to
appeal to an American audience it's also
just an inherent characteristic balsamic
I don't want to have 5 grams of sugars
every time I eat a salad so I use sherry
vinegar quite a lot I also use apple
cider vinegar which has a host of other
health benefits so in terms of vinegars
these are my two - most often used and
then olive oil a premium olive oil this
is not an olive oil that I would cook
with this is what you would consider a
finishing olive oil so you see this
repeating theme you have this like
cheaper all-purpose stuff that you use
for the cooking and then you have the
really nice stuff very fine flavor that
you would use for the finishing the
topic so I will put this on top of meat
I'll put it on top of vegetables to
finish right so let's say I cook
everything up put it on the plate then I
will take this off put my thumb over to
control and then drizzle this on
basically all the food and then take
Maldon sea salt put that on it crunch it
all over black pepper dash of lemon
juice and peel it back what did you do
this is amazing did you go to culinary
school no I just used these things it's
really simple and you can keep it simple
and of course you know you can refer to
one of these bad boys like this beast
the 4-hour chef but keeping it super
super basic this is all you need to make
incredibly delicious food in my
experience have you heard a five bullet
Friday well if you haven't that's good
news I'm excited because it is my most
exclusive content it is free and you can
check it out right here
lots of actionable tactics tools and
more